So we now have new polling that is post debate.
But I mean post last week's debate, there
was a debate last night.
We don't have any polls completed after last
night's debate, but last week, remember Michael
Bloomberg had this absolutely disastrous embarrassing
performance at the democratic debate, the
first debate in which he participated and
many people believed Bloomberg support would
absolutely implode because of how bad that
debate performance was.
And it was very, very bad.
But it didn't happen.
We now have two posts, debate polls, and Bloomberg
support is unchanged nationally from before
the first debate.
And he has actually grown support in some
key super Tuesday States.
And I believe Bloomberg will come away with,
uh, a respectable number of delegates on Tuesday.
Let's take a look.
Bloomberg went into last week's debate polling
right about 15% nationally and Bloomberg.
Now with two post debate polls is still polling
about 15% nationally.
The numbers highlighted in red on your screen,
our broom Bloomberg's pre-debate polls, you
see that he had 14 in each of the three most
recent pre debate polls and then you see the
numbers in blue, which are post-debate polls
where Bloomberg got a 13 and a 19 that is
essentially no change in Michael Bloomberg's
polling from before.
That absolutely terrible debate performance
and this is why I believe Michael Bloomberg
will by super Tuesday see a slight uptick
in support nationally merely because last
night he did a little bit better than last
week.
If you were convinced by Bloomberg's heavy
ad campaign spending to support them.
And then last night you see him come in, he
doesn't blow the roof off the place, but he
at least has some preparation.
You probably are comfortable voting for him
if you were planning do it already next week.
Now remember, I'm not a Bloomberg supporter.
I'm analyzing this from the perspective of
how he's running his campaign.
Bloomberg had about the worst debate performance
you can imagine last week and his support
didn't change.
And yesterday's PR debate performance still
made me cringe because of what he was saying,
including that he bought Congress, but he
was more prepared.
He had come back so they weren't great, but
he had them.
And an okay performance last night combined
with continuing to just pour money in is probably
going to grow his support by super Tuesday
a little bit more.
I know a lot of us just don't get it, like
how could this possibly be?
But I am telling you what I believe to be
true, not what I want to be true.
And meanwhile, let's look at some of the super
Tuesday polls.
Bloomberg is now polling in the delegates
in the, in the viability thresholds for delegates
in a number of States in California, there's
a poll that has Bloomberg at 21 can you imagine
as low as five a but as high as 21 in California.
In the latest poll in Texas.
Bloomberg is polling 18 would get them delegates
in North Carolina.
Bloomberg has surged to as high as 20 tied
for first place in one poll there, the civic
toss pole, then in Virginia, only one pole
there from last week.
But Bloomberg also tied for first place in
Virginia and then Florida, which is a huge
prize worth 219 delegates.
Bloomberg is straight up winning five points
ahead in Florida in the only poll from this
month.
What do you think is going on here?
Why is Bloomberg getting stronger despite
poor debate performances?
How many delegates is Bloomberg going to pull
on super Tuesday and understand the importance
to the math?
If you've been looking at the delegate math
and you understand that to secure the nomination
at the convention, you need 50% plus one of
the delegates, Michael Bloomberg pulling a
bunch of delegates from Florida, Virginia,
uh, maybe Texas, uh, California, possibly,
maybe North Carolina.
If Bloomberg does that, that makes the path
to 50% plus one far more difficult for every
other candidate.
Bloomberg has no delegates right now.
Every delegate Bloomberg gets is a delegate
that makes it more likely nobody gets to 50%
plus one my question to you is, why isn't
the guy losing
support after these disastrous debate performances?
Let me know.
I'm on Twitter at the Pacman.
We'll take a quick break and be back right
after this